in this video you're going to learn how
to write linear inequalities in one
variable and we're going to talk about
how to solve those and also how to graph
them on the number line we're going to
go through three examples so see if you
can practice some of these on your own
if you'd like and let's dive into the
first one here so it says twice a number
is at least five more than the number so
sometimes what I do is I kind of read it
through just quickly just to get a feel
for what it's talking about and then I
kind of go back and pick out some of the
important pieces so let's start off with
with this unknown number we could call
it n for number or a lot of times people
just like to use the variable X so we
could say twice a number so twice means
you're multiplying it by two so we could
say like two times our number X right is
at
least five more than the number now when
you look at this phrase here at least a
lot of times students will think H least
it sounds like less than right and you
might think okay let's write that less
than symol remember less than kind of
looks like an L tilted right greater
than is the other direction
but let's think about this a little bit
more closely at least say for example
you want to study at least an hour every
day could you study less than that like
a half hour no at least means that it
could be one hour or more right so it's
actually even though it sounds like less
than at least means that much or greater
so we're going to say greater than or
equal to five more than the number five
more than that means we're taking the
number and we're adding five more to it
so it's five more it's greater you know
we're adding five okay so now we have
our linear inequality in one variable we
want to solve it it's just like solving
an algebra equation right with an equal
sign but we want to get the variables on
the left and the numbers on the right so
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
subtract X from both
sides and you can see 2x - 1X is X is
greater than or equal to these cancel
five okay so pretty easy so as long as
our number is greater than or equal to
five it's going to satisfy uh this
inequality and we can graph this on the
number line say say for example here's
five here would be four and here would
be six okay as we're going to the right
the numbers are getting larger X is
equal to five so that means it's going
to be closed Circle if it was greater
than or less than but not equal to we
would draw it as an open circle like
Hollow or empty and the values of X are
greater than five may as you go to the
right it's getting larger or greater
another way students like to think about
this sometimes is that if your
variable's on the left you can think of
this as an arrow see how it kind of
looks like it's pointing to the right
and we're
graphing or shading to the right if it
was less than it'd be pointing the other
direction like this and we would be
shading to the left that only works
though if the variables on the left you
could also do like a test you could say
what's say if I put six in is six
greater than or equal to five yes so
that's where I would want to shade if it
was false then I would want to shade the
other direction let's take a look at
another example see if you can do this
one number two it says three times the
sum of a number and seven is at most
four times the number number minus 2 so
that's quite a bit going on there so
let's kind of read it again and break it
down so 3 * the sum of a number and
seven hm sum we know means addition okay
so some number X let's say and seven
we're going to add those together so x +
7 but it says three times that sum see
three times that sum is at most okay now
let's look at this phrase at most what
does at most mean say for example you
only want to watch TV at most two hours
a day right okay because you have to
study and do other things right could
you could you watch three hours of TV no
right because you said at most that's
your upper limit so you can watch two
hours of TV or less right or equal to
because at most is up to that amount but
not greater right so we could say this
is at most it sounds like more which
people thinks oh more greater than right
but at most means that much or less so
it's actually less than or equal to four
times
the number minus two okay so the number
is x minus 2 we know is subtract two but
it's four times oh I said that wrong
four times the number minus 2 four times
the number X right so four * a number
minus two okay so now we've got our
inequality let's solve it so first thing
I would do is just like it with an
algebra equation we want to simplify the
left side and the right side as much as
we can so I'm just multiplying or
Distributing this 3 so 3x +
21 and then now we want to get the
variables on one side and numbers on the
other ideally you want the variables on
the left and the numbers on the right
okay so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to subtract 4X from both
sides and then I'm going to subtract 21
from both sides okay so that comes out
to -1x is less than or equal to uh
-23 but we just want to solve for one of
the variables so instead of multiplying
by ne1 let's divide both sides
by1 and this is a important distinction
between solving equations and
inequalities what happens if you
multiply or divide both sides of the
inequality by a negative number that
inequality sign will actually Flip or
change direction now it doesn't matter
if there's negative numbers in the
problem it's just if you yourself
multiply or divide both sides by a
negative if you add or subtract a
negative it doesn't change it so in this
case I'm bring it over here this is X is
going to be flip the sign greater than
or equal to 23 let's go to our number
line here's
23 here's 24 here's 22 right so as you
go to the right the numbers are getting
bigger X is greater than or equal to so
equal to 23 or greater going to the
right now again you can think of when
the variable is on the left this is kind
of like an arrow telling us which dire
direction to graph or you could do a
test Point put 24 in is 24 greater than
or equal to 23 yes that's the right
direction if it was false you'd shade
the other side let's take a look at one
last
example okay see if you can do this
third and last example on your own if
you're up for it but we'll go through it
together as well so it says three less
than 5 * a number is less than the
difference of five in the number so
there's a lot going on there so think
about that want to try and do this
problem and while you do it I want to
make you aware of my video courses that
I have for sale I have an Algebra 1
video course and I have an algebra 2C
colge algebra video course for sale that
help you walk through those uh two
different courses step by step kind of
building on the previous Concepts and uh
explaining you know the theory and some
examples and have you practice some
examples on your own as well so if you
want some help going through those
classes and you like the way that I
explain things those courses are a great
resource uh for you but let's go to this
problem here now three less than five
times the number number okay see see how
I take it like little chunks so I think
about hm five times a number I know
let's say the number is x five times
that would be 5x now you see how it says
three less than that a lot of students
they like to translate like word by word
by word they see three they write the
number three they see less than they
think oh less than I'm subtracting minus
right but if we think about it three
less than five times a number means that
we're taking that quantity and we're
taking three away from it that's what
makes it three less than or three
smaller it's kind of like if you're
three years less than your your brother
three years younger right you would take
their age minus three to get your age
right now that quantity is less than so
we know less than it looks like an L
tilted so this quantity on the left is
smaller than right the difference now
what does difference mean that means
subtraction of five in the number so the
difference of five and the number okay
so now we've got our inequality let's go
ahead and solve it remember it's just
like solving an equation variables on
one side numbers on the other ideally
you want to get the variables on the
left if the numbers uh if it was the
variable ends up being on the right
let's say if it came out to four is less
than x you would pick it up and flip it
over but notice how this opens to the X
it's still going to open towards that X
so you want to make sure you flip the
whole thing okay even the the sign but
here let's go ahead and get the
variables on the left by adding
X let's get the numbers on the right by
adding three to both
sides some people like to draw a line
you can do that if that helps so 5x + 1
x is 6X -3 + 3 is 0 5 + 3 is 8 x and
negative X cancel out okay we just want
to solve for 1 x we're going to divide
both sides by six uh that comes out to X
is less than
4/3 which is 1 and
1/3 one and 1/3 okay so now if we graph
this on the number line let's just say
that this is uh one let's say this is
4/3 or 1 and A3 this is 5/3 which is 1
and 2/3 this is 2/3 1/3 so I'm kind of
counting by thirds here right so X is
less than 1 and 1/3 which we said is 4/3
so less than but not equal to so it's
open or Hollow doesn't include that
point notice that this arrow is pointing
to the left and that works at the
variables on the left or you can think X
is less than or smaller than as the
numbers get smaller we're going to the
left and that's the set of solutions
right there graphed on our number line
so great job if you're able to follow
these three examples if you want more
practice which I recommend math is all
about practice right follow me over to
that video right there that I did and
test yourself pause a video try and do
some of those problems and see if you're
getting them right I'll see you over in
that video